kevin how are you i'm good conan how you
doing buddy
i'm doing great you know i love that
you're standing this is very
dynamic what you're doing you're
standing you look like you're just
really ready to go
i do everything standing up now i have a
stand-up desk
i have a stand-up car
i have a stand-up bed everything's
standing for me now
a stand-up car in a stand-up bed that
just uh sounds
well it sounds idiotic i have to be
honest with you well it's not
let's not be name-calling so early right
you're right you're right let's let's do
this nicely you and i been friends
uh for quite a long time we hang out a
lot
and i happen to know that you recently
went through
shoulder surgery i saw you just before
you were going to have the surgery
how did it go well yeah there's the
what's left of the shoulder
it went well they replaced my shoulder
and you were nice enough to send me this
gift basket worth 167 dollars because
you left the receipt in the bag and of
course i looked at it
it's all bakery goods yeah i know i know
i just wanted you to know how much i
spent
it was 167 yeah of
of baked goods and that's a lot that's a
lot of money i spent on you
and but you know it was like six loaves
of bread
which i could never eat you know they
have and it was good bread too
it was from the uh nice bakery no
preservatives so it got moldy after an
hour
no i know that was the idea and then the
croissants and the chocolate croissants
and all the pastries i mean
i had to give a lot of it away to the
gardener okay
well i think it's the thought that
counts and the fact
that it cost a hundred and sixty seven
dollars but it was really nice here i
appreciate that and i've been telling
everybody like you asked me to
be good did you did you tell the trades
variety hollywood reporter
told the trades i told her uh deadline
good
but i think shoulder comes from the
stand-up desk
because i i still sit on my chair so
it's like
i'm always like reaching up
on my shoulder right so you have a
that's terrible a stand up de and you
still sit in a regular chair that's not
right
yeah yeah okay that's not good that's
not good you should probably stop doing
that
but you feel okay you can move you can
move the old wing as we call it no it's
been a couple of weeks so i'm not going
crazy it's just been this right side
yeah um but it feels actually pretty
good the hardest thing is sleeping at
night
yeah not because of the shoulders but
because of the stand-up bed
yeah and probably your conscience you've
done a lot of bad things in your life
that is true man but i have not been
canceled yet i have not been canceled
oh they'll get you they certainly will